Bruce some people say if we find the
theory of everything the crowning
achievement of modern science ever since
humans first began to ask what is the
world made of are we going to have
wonders technological wonders am I going
to get better color television am I
going to get better cable reception am I
going to get a better internet well the
short term answer is no it's not going
to affect your life or the life of
anyone directly but look at it this way
this theory of everything is also a
theory of space and time and the
universe itself it will answer some of
the deepest philosophical theological
questions of all time what happened
before Genesis chapter 1 verse 1
what happens if time can be bent into a
pretzel
what happens if space has holes in it
what happens if you could somehow
manipulate space and time itself
these questions are far beyond the
theories of Einstein Einstein's theory
breaks down at the instant of the Big
Bang where it's useless
Einstein's theory breaks down at the
center of a black hole what lies on the
other side of a black hole what lies on
the other side of a Big Bang Einstein's
theory are useless because they simply
blow up at that point this is where a
theory of everything comes in string
theory being a theory of everything
action allows us to go before the Big
Bang where there might have been a
multiverse of universes with our
universe being a bubble we live on the
skin of the bubble the bubble is
expanding and there are other bubbles
out there floating in 11 dimensional
hyperspace and these bubbles in turn are
connected perhaps by gateways by tubes
these are called wormholes and we
physicists take them very seriously
these wormholes may or may not be stable
we're not sure but they are definitely
part of the equations of the theory of
everything now another thing think of
human history as seen by a physicist in
terms of forces when Isaac Newton
worked out the first forest gravity that
gave us a mechanics that mechanics gave
us steam engines locomotives skyscrapers
the Industrial Revolution was in part
spurned on by the mastery of the first
force gravity the second force is the
electromagnetic force the force that
lights up our cities
laser beams computers all the electronic
wonders that we see around us is a
byproduct of the second force so when
physicists worked out the second force
that unleashed the electric and the
computer revolution and then the weak
and strong nuclear forces were worked
out in the last century that gave us
nuclear power that gave us the energy of
the stars the engine that drives the
entire universe so every time we
physicists worked out a force human
history changed and now we physicists
are working out the theory of everything
what will it eventually get us in the
short term nothing but in a long term it
may allow us to become masters of space
and time